JEREMY WALKER: Hi, my
name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm here for YouTube
Developers Live.
And today is all about GDEs.
What's a GDE, you might ask?
It's a Google Developer Expert.
These are people that help
us with supporting the APIs
and spreading knowledge
about the APIs.
So they help us answer
questions on stack overflow,
they talk at events, they
help us with hackathons.
There's lots of great stuff.
And we had a GDE
summit where a bunch
of them from around the
world came out to see us.
So we wanted to make sure
we pulled them in and did
a couple of interviews
with each of them
so we could see what
they were up to.
Our first one is from
Utah, Jarom McDonald.
And enjoy the show.
Next, we have our newest
addition to the team, Jarom.
He's from Utah.
So say hello.
JAROM MCDONALD: Hi,
how are you doing?
JEREMY WALKER: So we were
talking, before this event,
a little bit about the
live streaming API, which
for anybody that
doesn't know, it
allows you to tape live
events and put them up
on YouTube in real-time.
Can you tell us a little bit
about what you were telling me
about the opportunities you saw?
JAROM MCDONALD:
Being in education,
I think that the
live streaming API
is perfect for really
helping extend education
into distance fields, whether
we're talking about classrooms,
whether it's lectures, trying
to get more people involved
in educational opportunities.
The live stream in API
and its ease-of-use
is really poised
to do that well.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Is there anything
that surprised you
from when you started
from integration
with the live streaming API?
JAROM MCDONALD: I think
one of the biggest benefits
is the fact that you only have
to send one stream to YouTube
through the API.
And then YouTube takes
care of all the transcoding
for multiple devices
in multiple formats.
Most of the time when
you see platforms
like this they ask
you to send multiple
streams, but YouTube
just requires the one.
JEREMY WALKER: Right.
Yeah, that's true.
Anything that you'd request,
maybe to improve it?
JAROM MCDONALD: Probably just
requiring fewer subscribers
before allowing
someone to use the API.
Right now the limit on
the number of subscribers
is too high, according
to most developers who
want to get their
hands on this API.
JEREMY WALKER: Right.
It was 1,000.
And we've dropped it to 100.
And keep your eyes on that.
Well, thanks for joining
us here in Mountain View.
If you're in Utah,
I'm sure you'll
get to see Jarom quite a bit,
talking about the YouTube APIs.
But feel free to join us for
our next couple of interviews.